hey everyone
uh welcome to comic-con at home i'm so
happy you could join us for this
virtual panel with the cast and
producers of
the capture which is streaming
exclusively on
peacock my name is philiana a senior
editor of tv at entertainment tonight
and
we're going to be digging into this
excellent british drama
um that explores the kind of
increasingly
blurred lines between what's real and
what's not um in the show asked the
question in this kind of post-truth era
can we really believe what we see but
before we dig
into this series i'm going to introduce
the panelists who are spread out across
um two continents um first from the uk
we have
series creator writer and director ben
shannon
hello executive producer rosie allison
hello holiday granger who plays uh
detective inspector rachel
carey hi guys hi callum turner who plays
sean emery
hello uh and from the us we have ron
pearlman who plays frank napier
hi and famka janssen who plays
jessica mallory someone we meet later in
the series
hey everyone awesome hi guys thanks
thanks for
hopping on and doing this uh has this
been has it been a while since you've
all kind of seen each other
in kind of one room or
when you know how well been in lockdown
many many months i've seen it it was
about a year ago at a rat party
yeah i like the running gelsons actually
yeah but since then yeah i've just seen
a lot of column over the computer
awesome before we get into the q a we're
going to play the trailer just so
everyone at home can kind of get a
better idea of what the show is
ben do you want to kind of tee up what
the show is about
the show came about through um
my work in documentaries um as i
realized i worked
with the police quite a lot in
documentaries and i realized that um
increasingly people are getting uh
convicted through video evidence more
and more reliably
and at the same time you can now get
apps on your phone that take
uh you know do digital face transplants
that are
cheap effective and convincing i thought
to myself you know what if those two
technological and um and criminological
developments were to collide so that was
the kind of inspiration for it
cool uh yeah let's play the trailer
in the last few hours dramatic footage
has emerged online
depicting a man believed to be former
soldier sean emery attacking and
abducting a woman
that's him a woman's missing
and sean emery is our suspect
[Music]
is anyone going to tell me what a
problem is you're under suspicion for
assault and kidnapping
you do know that your suspect's a
national hero two tours in afghanistan
one in iraq and how do we repay his
service
you mind telling me where she is what
happened between you and hannah roberts
she kissed me she got on a bus that's
the last i see over
saying what happened this ain't what
happened none of this happened listen
real you what have you done
really
[Applause]
what do you mean he's gone he's escaped
from an emergency exit
run facial wreck make him a target
sean claims this has somehow been
fabricated
almost anything is possible these days
if properly done it's impossible to
prove
what are we tiptoeing around for i think
someone's tampering with evidence
we don't know whose turf we're treading
on
[Applause]
i understand you have this drive but
counter intelligence
you can rarely see the whole picture i
know
when they say move along nothing to see
they're lying
the police think i've done it my ex i've
done it between me and you there are
moments and i'm scared
if you knew he was at stake you would
walk away and pretend this
never happened the intelligence
community has hurt
a lot of people we need to find the
soldier find out which school
his daughter goes to if you could see
what we are working on
i'm talking about images that will haunt
you for the rest of your life
while you're watching everybody else
don't ever assume there isn't somebody
watching you
nice trailer i mean i'm i'm getting
anxious just kind of
like after that trailer how are you guys
feeling it's so good to see it again
it's been so long it
made me feel really excited it's pretty
dynamic
it's one of the um i mean it's very rare
to have a writer director
do the whole thing so ben has both
written
all six episodes directed them all and
he just he's a master storyteller and he
came up
with this extraordinary sort of
unmissable thriller where you
really it makes you think it's got the
big picture
um the big picture paranoia about the
uncertainty of digital manipulation but
he also was
very sure to make you feel as well and
so he's got these
two fantastic lead characters
sean the soldier who's caught on cctv
apparently committing a crime which he
denies and then
holliday the detective who begins
to investigate and unravel the truth of
what really happened and is our sort of
um
eyes on the moral maze of the story but
uh
but it's all credit to ben so i should
stop talking but uh it's really rare to
find this master storyteller who can do
all these things and
bring them together
[Laughter]
thank you very much i mean i certainly
didn't realize
how contemporary it was going to be um i
started writing this before the term
deep fake
i thought i'd heard of it before it
became a
common phrase even fake news wasn't
really a
household phrase when i started writing
and then as i was writing
the sort of the news started to catch up
with the story
and i started to fact factor in the
language of the day into the into the
dialogue otherwise it would have
felt weird people not referencing those
things but clearly
we're living through a time when every
piece of footage every piece of news is
being questioned and rightly so
but then the flip side of that is that
that's being exploited by people as well
and the point where it suits
certain politicians to um if we don't
quite know what's real
yeah i mean you kind of mentioned the
two kind of amazingly characters
holiday you play rachel who is this
ambitious
kind of eager um very skilled detective
who's kind of thrown into the mix
in this high-profile sean emery case
right
uh what stood out to you about rachel
that
that kind of immediately drew you in
um i kind of loved that when i first
started
reading the scripts i didn't know if i
liked her or not
um and that it was it was a sort of
because she doesn't really care it's
like she's there to do a job and she's
ambitious and she wants to do well and
prove herself and
um you know she's she kind of um she's
not
necessarily a people pleaser um and i
just love ben's um the way that ben's
weave such an
moral conundrum for carey throughout the
whole series that she's
um you know when we first meet her she
has such faith
in the authorities and the institution
of the police and
but she also has it like an incredibly
strong moral compass and a
need to fight for and get to the bottom
of the truth and when those two
aspects of her sort of of her faiths
like collide
um it's this is kind of complete yeah
moral maze that she goes through
awesome and and callum i mean first of
all congratulations on on your
after tv nomination was that a pleasant
surprise
yeah it was a lovely surprise yeah yeah
what intrigued me about sean was kind of
there's a point in the series when even
he starts to question his own
understanding of the truth
um as an actor how did you kind of
approach playing
that internal struggle like he's
constantly on edge
well i was i was so shown as like a
freedom fighter of his own mind
in in some sense because you meet this
man as
he's in the limelight he's famous for
something that no one wants to really be
famous for for killing someone
and he's questioning how he got there
how he got to that place and he's
really trying to change how the world
views him how
his family view him how his how his
friends view him how he views himself
and he's he's about to do that um
he gets off with the case in the first
episode and then he's dragged back into
this nightmare and
um on a higher level it could be like a
long day's journey into
the night kind of man searching for his
soul
journey that he goes on and i just
wanted to do that and then on top of
that there was
working with ben and holiday and and
rosie and those guys in the bbc
and uh and and the character that was
really intelligent
i think both the characters that holiday
and i have are working out as we're
going along
and alongside the audience and i think
that's one of the reasons it's so
gripping because no one's ahead of
anyone at any stage
yeah definitely um ron i mean you've
made a career out of
of playing badasses i feel like like
cowboy and
clay and and sons of anarchy um frank
kind of falls under that umbrella too
but there's
a limit to his power um what was
appealing to you about
frank and the lengths that he kind of
goes to
complete his mission
very similar to what holiday said you
know um
first thing you want to do is figure out
where you fit into this story
and the thing that was so smart about
the way ben rendered frank was that
um all the way to the end you don't know
whether you're dealing with the good guy
or the bad guy
you don't know whether you're supposed
to feel sympathy for the for this guy's
plight
or how he views his place in the world
and his job
um or whether he's a monster um
and will do anything in order to um
justify his agenda um
his agenda seems rather to be the
tail that's wagging the dog um
and so the whole kind of thing is a
is a mind i can't use the word right
well anyway if i if i could use the word
mind
i would use it but i can't so um
but uh the notion of of
there not being any relief for the
audience to figure out
wait a minute um i'm i'm having so much
trouble
keeping track of who's the good guy here
who's the bad guy
here and you know frank uh is the head
of the class when it comes to
that head fake definitely
um you're you're no stranger to playing
fierce women and jessica mallory
although she doesn't come in
until like late into the season jessica
mallory
is someone who kind of lures over frank
a little bit right
uh and and your introduction kind of you
make quite a splash when you come in
uh what do you want people to know about
jessica and what did you like about
this character foremost i was very
excited to be part of the project
because i thought ben did such an
incredible
job with the screenplays and
i've been spending my time between
london and new york for the last couple
of years and i was just struck when i
was in london
but how many cctv cameras there are i've
never seen anything quite like it
so um and i'm very i'm one to
get very much involved in the whole big
brother sort of conspiracy theory and
whatever so
when i read this piece i was like this
is so of the moment this is so timely
this whole notion of fake news of not
knowing what's real
constantly having to fact check and
double check everything
and this is an absolutely frightening
notion of what
could happen in the world and where we
you know in the world that we live in
today and so i thought it was
the story that had to be told and it was
done so well by ben
and then the cast that he put together
is you know
rosie obviously is an amazing producer
so it was just a
there was it was a no-brainer in terms
of signing up to do it
and um uh we uh
ron and i just worked on ashford the
year prior a movie
uh that ron also produced and so it was
really nice to come in
and have a different dynamic between us
as characters than we had before and
sort of coming in as this
looming you know dark figure from
the cia and we're not entirely sure
what her motives are and how deep this
um potential conspiracy or whatever it
is
runs so those were some of the reasons
why
i ended up saying yes to this plus i got
to be in london which is one of my
favorite places in the world so
yeah pretty awesome deal um for the cast
i mean
were you familiar with this world before
uh
what kind of prep work did you do to
become familiar with this world if you
weren't before and
and to play your characters and yeah
i felt like i was familiar with the uh
detective world just from watching
detective shows you know like i love
killing i love the bridge
um i've and i've always been a fan of
them but you know i didn't really know
much about
the actual police force um but ben's
scripture was so well researched that
reading them i felt like i
you know i could see the differences
between my expectations and what was on
the page
um but i managed to get a um
i should worm my way in with the met
and do a weeks shadowing um
in the homicide department um and also
shadowed a couple of other
women that were at her at carrie's level
that had a similar background to her
and that had transferred freshly to
homicide and that was
just to see what actually happens
and to pick people's brains as well to
just you know try and find a whole
intense script and there weren't any
it was like you know to like to say does
this really happen would this happen
like
um and just the terminology used and
everything was
um was amazing and also ben set up um
a few meetings with his counterterror
advisor which was
completely like eye-opening and
mind-blowing
as to you know what is probably
happening
what's possibly happening what
definitely is happening um
yeah that was interesting you ended up
on a actual murder investigation huh
no i did i like well i kind of there
were like
three what i was surprised with is how
many invest
like like a homicide uh detective how
many um
investigations they cover at the same
time and one of them
was a cold case that was in my area and
i ended up
on a she'd not been to the crime scene
before so i ended up on a walk around of
the crime scene in my local area
and because i knew the park better than
them i was just like oh no no this is
the
quickest entrance this is the nearest
entrance to the pond and these are the
woods and
felt like i was like you know i was
determined i was gonna solve that i was
they were still looking for the body
like a few years later and i still think
when i walked through that path i
might come across it wow that's amazing
i mean callum what kind of shocked or
surprised you in kind of researching
like surveillance culture and and doing
research
to the thing that actually shocked me
the most was how much fun soldiers have
when they're on tour
and how much uh enjoyment there is and
how it becomes quickly their normality
um
there's i guess being so close to death
all the time you have to live every
moment as it comes
with as if it is your last moment you
know your friends are not everyone's
dying all the time but people die around
you and and you are close to that
um and that was the thing that surprised
me most and then also i did some weapons
training
uh which was interesting and some
surveillance stuff too you aced the
weapons training
why was it interesting why was it
interesting
because they're so powerful and loud and
they're shooting i'm shooting a sniper
is
it's it's a quite an intense experience
and and i hadn't
shot um i've shot handguns before i
haven't shot a massive
it hurts you know your surveillance
training sounded intense as well
yeah my surveillance training well i
think i'm a bit jealous of you for that
i think i
want to go and just like try and try and
dodge i should do it for the next
yeah maybe i should you should hook that
up
it was a lot of fun i ended up following
people around london trying to avoid
getting caught and then
um and then uh and then trying not to
get caught
growing my mum it was a lot of fun wow
that's amazing um
i mean for for ron and maybe
fanca to me as a viewer just watching
this show like
i found myself kind of trying to crack
the code on on who was actually good who
was evil who was telling the truth his
story
actually believe did you find yourself
kind of doing that as you were reading
the scripts and as you were kind of
filming
that's one of the reasons why i signed
on because it is really
it was a page turner and it's in the
same when you watch it it's
constantly you're constantly questioning
everything and everybody um you know
what is the truth
and that is something that we're just
dealing with on a daily basis today it
is
so absolutely of the moment it's so
timely this show so i
you know that is incredible i wish i had
been able to do
any kind of on the ground cia
type of but i have no connections there
because that would have seemed
fascinating to be you know with people
like that
um next time one day hopefully
yeah i i i feel horrible that i don't
have
great stories to um share with you about
my research and
stuff that callum and holiday were
talking about about
ride-alongs and shadowing i wish i had
i realized that i was joining a world um
that uh i didn't know a great deal about
in terms of
you know the internal um administrations
of how things uh
uh responsibilities are handed down and
what
one does in the name of pulling one's
weight
and uh so for me
um it was deferring completely to
uh to ben this was his world he had a
very
strong notion about um
not only the world that i was occupied
but uh but also how he interacted with
all of the other
uh areas of law enforcement you know
all the areas of law enforcement are are
represented in the show
you have local you have state you have a
federal international and you know where
frank comes in is like
you know he's a stranger in a strange
land he's an american
operative in the uk so immediately
everybody looks at him side-eyed and
suspect
and as if he has some sort of a strange
representation of some diabolical
thing that exists on the other side of
the pond so right off the bat
he's being regarded askew
and then you meet him and you realize
that's very justified
um that you know
people should be uh uh suspect
of uh what america's interests are and
um what what what particularly what this
guy's
um modus operandi uh
includes um in the name of keeping
people safe
[Music]
where does that concept end
and some sort of personal agenda about
human rights begin and so
that's the exercise of frank and for me
it was
um an exercise in deferring to the
filmmaker the guy who wrote the thing
and the guy was gonna
actually you know get these performances
out of us in order to
um um realize his vision
and that was that was everything to me
for for the actors i mean how has your
role in in this show
um kind of changed your view on on
surveillance and hasn't made you more
aware of cameras and and
made you come more protective of your
own kind of personal privacy
i've definitely uh started noticing
cameras
more than i did before and i'm
they're incredibly private as a person
um i don't do social media anything that
you know
just to protect my privacy everything is
turned off on my phone
in terms of location services and all
that kind of stuff but
just knowing the ends to which people
can go and how incredibly complicated it
is in today's world to
have any type of privacy and what you do
and say can be used
against you um and then with
manipulation of
existing um footage makes it
even more frightening to me it's almost
like um
all of the all of the the care you take
in preserving your um privacy
what this show did for me was say it
doesn't really matter what you do
they're listening and they're watching
and they can do anything that they
want with that information depending on
what kind of mood they're in at any
given time
which is or depending on who's sitting
in the in the seat of power
um which comes into play in this story
as well
um you know we have politicians in high
places and
all around the world that are telling
you you didn't see what you just saw
uh those are our leaders so what what
kind of a shot do we have at maintaining
you know some sort of a real perspective
i think
the timing of ben wanting to tell the
story is just
phenomenal one of the um one of the
things that comes through so clearly
from the show is that we all know
the phrase big brother is watching you
but what ben's done is taking it to the
next level and so big brother is not
just watching you he can do
all these different things with your you
know it's the digital manipulation
element that is really scary and is the
next step
in personal paranoia yeah i mean that
kind of leads into my
next question kind of perfectly like has
your paranoia kind of grown as a result
of
of being part of this project well 19
1984
brave new world two of my favorite books
um
and i know ben loves them too and uh
what's so brilliant about the show is it
stays true to the conspiracy thriller
um nature of it you know uh the
parallax views and uh is it three nights
on the condo three nights on the
three days in the people three days yeah
three days of the condo that kind of
those kind of movies and it stays true
to that and
and takes us on the journey it's also i
think
f4 is kind of like rambo first blood i
don't know what you think then
i know i love it that it didn't matter
to me when i wrote it but when you said
it i thought yeah okay
that's a good movie it's another 70s
movie right the 70s
or is it 1980 might be 80s yeah
come on rosie you know i don't know when
it was
that's not my thing is possibly 1980 but
is that is that sort of i would add
blower
blow out blow up and blow out to the to
the list of things
films that inspire this the conversation
publication
just conversation yes yeah i mean to
have those movies as your inspiration
you know and put it into today's world
[Music]
yeah and there is just that whole thing
that we've all grown up thinking that
there is such a thing as documentary
evidence and it's a gold standard
and and now we're in an age where we
just have to accept that
documentary evidence just ain't
documentary evidence anymore necessarily
i'm going through this really weird
period where i just
find the the notion of how much
information we have access to
and and how much is just being poured on
us on a daily basis
because of the 24-hour news cycle and
social media and
things ways of getting uh
tidbits of situations that are so
outlandishly unjust that you can't do a
thing about
so you know at what point do you
completely
turn off at what point you become
cynical at what point do you give up
um at what point do you say you know i
can't
remember for the grace of god go i i
can't fix
all of the ills of the world so i'm just
gonna stick to my little tiny
little corner you know i'll watch that
great line
you know i'm going to just sit in my
little
little couch from watching my little 60
inch tv and
just leave me alone let me have my beer
um
but yeah it's it's overwhelming i mean
for me
i didn't even know anything about the
concept of cctv
until i read the script then i arrived
in london
and um everywhere every time i looked up
somebody was looking back at me this is
something that i hadn't
even begun to you know
fold into to my consciousness because
you guys don't have anything else to
worry about i mean you know
now what do i do about that you know as
if i don't have enough to worry about
well um yeah i mean because this is
comic con and many of you have kind of
ties to big franchises like
x-men and hellboy and fantastic beasts i
have to ask like what do you guys geek
out over
uh personally like what is your kind of
big nerd obsession
i'll start with holiday um do i geek out
over
and i mean i think he already said at
the beginning like it was like detective
shows um
so like the killing the bridge luther
um crime suspect um
yeah what's your name
series that's mine
i still geek out over cary grant
i'm sorry that's my um
you know black and white 30s and 40s
movies
um are my refuge that's where i escaped
to
um the notion of a more ordered
world less self-indulgent world a more
sophisticated world where
not everybody was crying in their beer
um
people were just getting on with it and
the the level of
discourse was erudite and sophisticated
and dripping with charm
no matter what i do that's what i keep
going back to that's my refuge
mine's mine's always comedies and it
varies in its uh
in my watching i'm watching a lot of
modern family right now
i love that show and and ben
and rosie what about you guys i i
geek out over hellboy uh x-men
nothing beast harry potter
um
seinfeld is my is the thing that i just
i've watched all my life i continue to
watch it i watch it with my family
throughout lockdown it's kind of kept us
saying there's not much better than
eating a pizza and watching seinfeld
it's a good shower
and in time in time of sorrow i turn to
gene kelly he's my go-to
particular numbers that i watch over and
over but i did just
watch normal people twice i enjoyed that
so much the uh
on that show yeah
um awesome well lastly before we rap i
mean one thing the capture
gets at is that the truth is very
complicated
right and and extremely layered um
and and the show also kind of raises
very important moral questions
um then i'll throw it to you what do you
want people to take away
from the series and what questions you
want
people to ask that they didn't before
i suppose the central question is in a
world where
every piece of video footage could be
manipulated uh how how can we believe
what we see
awesome very succinct uh cool well i
think that's all the time we have i mean
thank you so much for joining
the cast and producers of the capture
for this virtual comic-con at home panel
you can watch
all six episodes of the first season
exclusively on
nbc universal streaming service peacock
and the series will be back for a second
season at some point
um yeah thanks again to ben rosie
holiday callum ron and
bonka for a great discussion thanks guys
nice to see you okay everybody
great to see everybody big money
lots of love guys
lovely painting oh thank you i just
finished it and i had to cover it
there so i wanted to improvise and cover
the painting that was
not that i didn't do so i thought
how lovely yes i i paint
in lockdown for months it's wonderful
such a great hopping down beautiful it's
really nice yeah
great all right
nice thing everybody
you